monday edition of pft ot where we get to
some of the things we were able to get
to during our two-hour program on nbcsn
and chris i want to start
with the acknowledgement from over the
weekend by the nhl that when and i guess
there's still a tiny element of if they
resume their season with a 2014
postseason that will be a chase for the
stanley cup
they plan to test players
every day and some people are surprised
by that but look
the locker room petri dish especially
hockey and football if somebody's sick
if somebody's positive even if you're
not sick you can still have the virus
it's going to run through that locker
room quickly so every day yes you need
to be sure the players are negative and
i'm a believer you have to make sure
they're negative as they leave the
facility don't want to unleash them on
the community after they've become
positive while they're at work so test
them on the way in test them on the way
out every single day that's what the nfl
is going to have to be ready to do and
the nfl has the benefit of watching
these other sports watch and see what
happens with the nhl watch and see what
happens with the other sports but i
think it's a no-brainer you've got to
test everyone before they go into the
building every given day that doesn't
mean you have to test them on the days
they stay at home but when they come
back to work the next day you better
test them before you let them in yeah
well i think the first thing is mike i
mean you're right i want to see major
league baseball nba nhl get going a
little bit to set some sort of
president's uh precedence for the nfl or
for any business going forward but yeah
selfishly you and i want to see the nfl
play football you know one for our for
our work and jobs and everything like
that but man we love football we love
watching it so it would help if these
other organizations would get going to
just maybe help out or you know iron out
some of the wrinkles that you could have
the unforeseen circumstances but i'm
with you i don't know why people are
surprised first off in the fact that
they're surprised players are gonna be
tested daily i mean that that has to
happen i mean i just feel like you know
one players aren't going to feel
comfortable i feel like society
ultimately won't be feel comfortable if
the players are going about that on an
everyday basis you know you know you
bring up a good point about twice a day
i'm not so sure that's necessary as long
as you're being strict about testing
everybody from the get-go when they
enter the building i would hope that
would be enough i would hope we wouldn't
have to use two tests per day on a
person or whatever it may be but uh
either way yeah i want to see one of
these other leagues get going just to
start the process and kind of see how it
all goes
one thing that i don't know and at some
point i need to get the answer to is how
long it takes to show up that you are
positive for the virus once you have it
in your body because i guess in theory
there's a way that you could test
negative
still have it
and then by the time you leave the
facility at the end of the day if you're
there 12 hours right
maybe you are shedding virus and
potentially infecting others before you
leave so there's a lot of medical
information that needs to be factored
into this and and there still needs to
be advances in the testing so you can
get
an answer are you positive are you
negative as quickly as you possibly can
so you can can go about your day you
don't want to have somebody sitting in
an airlock at the team facility for an
hour
waiting for their their uh test result
you have a backlog how many people can
get in there as you're testing them on
the way in i mean these are all
logistical things that everyone is going
to need to figure out if these sports
are going to come off as planned and and
and that's why i've constantly been
asking the why how where what questions
i don't want football or any other sport
but primarily chris you and i are
selfish about football i don't want
football to get to september
and they start implementing their plan
and then they look around and like this
didn't work what the hell are we doing
we can't do this
see you next year so i i'm and i'm
trusting i'm trusting
maybe i shouldn't i don't know i'm
trusting that people smarter than me and
who have a stronger incentive than i do
to ensure that football has played this
year are figuring this stuff out and
when i remember that these are the folks
who brought his past interference replay
review last year i start to get a little
concerned
well i i hear you but you know like this
is this is where again this is like to
me the conversation realistically like
realistically do we really think all 32
teams
started in the fall that nobody's going
to come down with kobe 19 again i mean i
just i don't think there's any way and
you know again this is where i think the
nfl and the nfl pa need to start having
some more in-depth conversations here
you know i saw the article you wrote
towards the end of last week right on
friday about taylor decker you know i i
thank you for referencing me i know you
s in the article you wrote how you know
i've been trying to say for weeks and
taylor decker kind of said the same
thing where he's not personally worried
about cobit 19. yes he'll respect you
know the guidelines and he certainly
doesn't want to infect anybody else or
do anything like that but he himself as
far as it pertains to himself and
affecting him he doesn't care and that's
to me mike where just it still comes
down to we got to start getting some
polling and some questioning out there
with the players to know like hey
players if 10 guys in a locker room on a
given week all of a sudden test positive
what do you want to do if that happens
do we want to just quit the season or
are we just going to say hey the hell
with it we're young and healthy and
we're gonna push forward you know those
are the things that i just i we still
don't know and i don't know you're right
that's why i want to see these other
sports get started too so maybe they can
deal with the problems and the nfl can
come up with you know ways to solve it
you know one thing that i said all
through the month of april once the
draft comes and goes the remainder of
the off season rockets by maybe comes
june june becomes july july becomes
football season and here we are first
day of june and there are still plenty
of questions but at least the nfl will
have the benefit of seeing how it
unfolds in some of these other sports
and like i said these folks have a hell
of a lot more financial incentive than
we do to make sure their product is
televised more importantly than anything
else whether or not fans show up but uh
that this is all still kind of up in the
air and the problem is
with
the social unrest
consuming so much of the news coverage
now
i feel like we've become
not quite desensitized to the
coronavirus we've just kind of forgotten
about it yeah a little bit uh and you
know what in all these places where
there are these protests and people are
packed together i know a lot of them
have masks on but
man i i just i hope that second wave
doesn't come a hell of a lot sooner
because of mass gatherings in a bunch of
different american cities but uh these
are all things that are gonna unfold as
the the summer continues to unfold and
we'll see where it leads is chris but
the nhl
planning to test every day the nfl needs
to follow suit and taylor decker echoes
something you've been saying ever since
this first started players want to play
they want to play and they want to get
paid they take risks far more immediate
when they walk onto a football field
than whether or not they may end up with
covet 19 so they are just wired to not
care about it because they're already
wired to not care about the possibility
of suffering a serious injury on any
given snap in any given game all right
one of the things about the pandemic
that actually may help certain teams the
ability of coaches
to basically stay home and enter the
laboratory and come up with new ways of
of running their team specifically
offense specifically the cardinals cliff
kingsbury and this is an item that we
have at pft it comes from bob mcmanaman
of the arizona republic cliff kingsbury
has spent time
diving into the college game studying up
on offenses figuring out what's work and
it works and it's got uh
it's got um players on that team
intrigued by what cliff kingsbury is
going to ultimately have ready for them
when they reconvene and get ready for
the season
yeah well i think this is a common theme
throughout the nfl right now that
coaches are getting to
kind of uh dabble into a little bit more
research or do those type of things as
far as looking at other films and
incorporating new ideas to their
offensive defensive schemes you know the
biggest thing is there's more time
during the day you know the guys aren't
at the facility there's not as many
coaches meetings you know of course
you're not meeting with the players and
having to walk through the day is not
consumed you know the same way so i
think it is allowing some coaches to do
some other projects as far as uh just
outside the box thinking cliff kingsbury
hey this was the big question i had he
answered it for me last year but one of
the reasons i went well i'm not so sure
this is a great hire by the arizona
cardinals is just because
hey cliff kingsbury i just wasn't sure
how much offense he knew really he kind
of just taught that texas tech red
raiders type offense and i just wasn't
sure is he going to be able to bring
more to the table all right where he
proved me wrong is one he stole a lot of
ideas from different offenses around nfl
football last year that that makes me
feel good that's what a smart human
being does you see other smart human
beings doing something that works you go
home let me see if i can steal that and
make that work for my team
so he sure certainly showed that ability
i like that and then yeah i think with
cliff kingsbury and having a better
understanding of what the nfl game is
now he probably has a better
understanding of what he can and can't
steal from the college game now to
incorporate into his offense that might
be more of effective and he knows what
his offense is going to look like and he
knows what to expect from defenses so
i'm excited for it too let alone with
you know some new players there in
arizona it really is amazing that a guy
who was questioned by many probably
including us
yeah he's using record at texas tech
what did he do he had patrick mahomes a
guy who may go down as the greatest
player of all time he had patrick holmes
and what the hell did he do
so uh the fact that cliff kingsbury is
finding his niche finding his groove
making it work at the nfl level it's
refreshing to see it and and you're
right that lack of ego and pride that
will
cause you know when you when you have
that ego and pride you've got you've got
coaches who say i'm doing it my way
i'm only doing it my way the willingness
to find other things uh and use other
things
that's that's smart and it could prove
to be very beneficial for the cardinals
yeah definitely and you know that's
that's ultimately you know what cliff
kingsbury is is he's smart
he's a great communicator he really is
he understands how to talk to people and
teaching offense and teach people that
aspect of it so because of that you know
he really fits the nfl game he really
does and he understands it that way and
it's a players league and i think cliff
kingsbury understands that as well but
uh this is a very you know intelligent
outside the box type uh type of thinker
and yeah mike i mean i saw things last
year where i went i mean are they ever
gonna get underneath the center oh i saw
kyle murray underneath the center saw
him running 49ers play action passes and
sean mcvay's play action passes and all
these things for me to sit there and go
okay this guy gets it he understands
that like what he did at texas tech is
not going to work week in week out play
after play in the nfl he needs to add
more to the arsenal and he did that and
then i think you know again with some of
the aggressive moves they made to get
kenyon drake and deandre hopkins he has
more of a vision of how he wants his
offense to really look for this year so
the cardinals you know i know you and
you and me both are excited about them
this year i mean it might not translate
to playoffs or a lot of wins because man
that is some tough division but
nonetheless i expect them to be a fun
team to watch an exciting team and i
think they are one of those teams in the
nfl with like the arrow up uh and it's
all going in the right direction there
looking good for the next few years
think about this remember those days
when the cardinals were in the nfc east
for crown out loud the arizona cardinals
for about what
15 years or so after they moved from st
louis and they never should have been in
the east anyway when they were in st
louis but after they moved from saint
louis arizona they were in the nfc east
if they were in there now they'd be the
team to beat
right they would be yeah you're right
the cowboys what a rivalry that would be
cardinals and cowboys this year if they
played twice and we're competing in the
division
timing is everything you know hey you're
right you know again hey the 49ers
joe montana and them would they have
been the same if they had to play in
this nfc west now i don't know they got
to play in nfc west that you know
everybody was you know nobody was that
great so they got to beat up on those
teams and be fresh for the playoffs used
to piss me off as a young kid i used to
sit there going oh man my dad's being
killed by reggie white and the cowboys
and the redskins and they're all
fighting and then here comes the 49ers
in the playoffs they're all fresh and
feeling good because they just walloped
the rest of the nfc west and then i was
always worried about the giants that way
but yeah i hear you and i'm excited i
mean murray hopkins cliff kingsbury
isaiah simmons chandler jones i mean
they're starting to build some names
there
and some people we can really kind of
latch on to in arizona that makes uh
makes them one of the more exciting
teams in the nfl
by the way the cardinals get an
opportunity to have a reunion with their
nfc east rivals they play all four of
those teams this year as does the rest
of the nfc west and they also play all
the teams of the afc east and that
brings me back to a point that we've
made before now that there are three
wild card teams per conference you get
the nfc east the afc east
if we get and i always when it comes to
this these these various things the nfl
does always like the chaotic outcome and
having all four teams from the same
division in the playoffs would be
awesome
it would be i i i mean it would be
amazing
it's uh it was always cool to see three
teams from the same division get in
there in the old format to have four
teams that would be unreal and would
lead to some
bad blood type games in the playoffs
because they're going to have to play
each other and as you know when you have
to play a team for the third time during
a season things get personal and that's
always fun to watch on the football
field do you still hate joe montana
no not at all i mean like he so you
would think that you did you admit that
you did that was a lot of questions
football football hate like football
hate yes i mean yeah like you know the
49ers like just irked me of course yeah
i looked at look at the 49ers and go i
think my dad might have won another
super bowl or two of them weren't for
that damn 49er football team so uh yeah
they'll always bother me but as you know
there's someone there now that i like so
i tend to root for the 49ers now
the uh the the giants the year that they
won the super bowl in 86 that was you
know that was like one year after the 85
bears it was like this dominant team
with this great defense like
back-to-back years two different teams
it was just odd to see that that that
consecutive like that for the page to
turn so abruptly from the bears to the
giants and it felt like the giants were
gonna have staying power and they did
they won a super bowl just a few years
after that
yeah well you know and really mike you
could even further that because the 1984
49ers they were 15 and one too so it was
really like dominant 49ers team who beat
the bears in the playoffs and then the
bears were like man okay now we know
what it takes to be a super bowl team
they went and dominate and go 15-1 beat
the giants in the playoffs the giants
i've heard my dad and laurence taylor
tell the story about how you know it
made them realize they had to raise
their intensity a level well the next
year they go 14-2 and you know kick butt
in the playoffs and with the super bowl
and all that but that to me is like one
of the golden ages of the nfl football
there that was a time where man there
was only about five or six teams that
you knew could really win the super bowl
and they were all in the nfc and they
were all fighting each other on a
year-to-year basis
all right we could keep talking but
we've been talking long enough we're
gonna end it until tomorrow everybody
check us out at profootballtalk.com
there'll be a new chris sims unbutton
coming on tuesday a new pft live coming
tuesday morning chris great work as
always have a great day everybody be
smart be safe and uh let's keep working
our way through these issues that have
caused so much consternation and
controversy in recent days and let's
let's pray that we can work our way
towards some real solutions for the
better of everyone of all americans of
all human beings hopefully we will get
there everyone uh have a good day and
we'll see you tomorrow
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports